amerika ist wahrscheinlich die heimat
des comfort food nirgendwo sonst
versteht man so gut was man essen muss
um sich für den moment gut zu fühlen und
nirgendwo sonst ist es so egal wie es
einem nach rache geht so kann man sich
relativ gut beschreiben und wir sind
hier beim frühstück das ist am heutigen
tag auf jeden fall die am wenigsten
komplexe mahlzeit weil amerikaner haben
nicht so eine gigantische frühstücks
kultur erinnert euch vielleicht habe
schon mal so ein full american breakfast
gemacht nach susan bacon pancake sonst
was habe ich aber schon 23 mal gezeigt
deshalb sage ich ein bisschen variation
stop platz geholt wo ich ganz ehrlich
sagen muss ich weiß nicht was mich
erwartet und sandwich tost erdnussbutter
und marmeladen mit anderen worten china
daily zu sagen während wird das paradies
henrich zubereiten machen wir aber schon
mal ein frosted strawberry
während wir die scheiße machen als aller
erstes mal patzen dies übrigens jetzt
einfach auch in deutschen supermärkten
vereinzelt zu kaufen gibt
das sicher nicht übel aus einmal frost
strawberry so rein postet ihr einmal
kurz auf der weiß nicht ob dabei die
hochspringen
ich habe jetzt gerade gesagt das am
wenigsten besondere heute weil wir
krasse sachen vorhaben heute abend wird
endstufe auch aber ist natürlich
trotzdem besonders weil das hat jetzt
auch ein deutscher frühstückstisch
relativ wenig platz ich habe leider kein
ray kelly bekommen weil das wäre das
heftigste so dieser trade flavour den
gibt es ja bei uns eigentlich gar nicht
haben keine getränke mit ray player wir
haben keine marmeladen mit also trauben
geschmack kriegst du gar nicht aber in
amerika ist das ein riesending sollen
die ganz amerikanisch gehen weil ich
meine hier schneiden den rand ab gewann
hier die leute sagen dass ich immer so
viel mühe beim kochen gehört
auf jeden fall ein gutes beispiel dafür
ist sondern wer denkt dass wir dieses
toastbrot für peter gillies kosten
derzeit auf jeden fall geschnitten es
ist fast so ein bisschen als würde man
so die zubereitung von greenpeace at
which erklären der name ist das rezept
peanut butter and kelly sowie
beschmieren beide seiten ich sage
ehrlich ich hatte mal eine phase das
jetzt was für die ganz krankenhaus ist
bevor ich selbst youtube videos gemacht
habe habe ich so minecraft videos
geschaut immer auf youtube und habe für
pirelli sandwiches dabei gegessen
strawberry jam
decke drauf und das wird nicht getestet
aber extra nicht getauscht hat ich finde
es auch krass dass also in amerika ist
ja so gutes brot wirklich eine
seltenheit und von griechischen post
rutschten ende sogar den rand
wenn ihr ausgewogenes frühstück hört
dann sagt seid ehrlich denkt jedoch auch
einen fiesen teller hier zu viel
raffinierter zucker da drin einfach
krank aber no joke das liebe ich freue
mich trotzdem drauf weil ich habe
irgendwie schon immer so eine
faszination auch für amerikanisches
essen womit fangen wir an
die software ist ob es ist so ich glaube
im idealfall wahrscheinlich beides aber
ins stocken er hat keine probleme
schnelle bälle
hält es würden ja irgendwie haben
also dieser kontrast ist wirklich da
schmeckt halt trotzdem das ist nicht gut
für dich nicht das ding ist auf 20
prozent und macht das schmeckst du auch
aber trotzdem deshalb länger jetzt
aubert
dritte nach pisa das wirkt sich dies ist
auch der zuschauer das tut fast weh und
ist es schokolade auf jeden fall meinen
brief von den beiden das feld nicht
werden urteil dazu zu fassen als ist das
für mich kein prüfstein also auch als
ich in amerika werden 23 meisten dort
habe ich nicht immer schwer getan wenn
ich nicht im hotel frühstücken wollte
wenn du dann so raus gehst auf die
straße und jetzt hier der inbegriff von
amerika ein randlos android mit
erdnussbutter und marmelade
charity dieser geschmack ich habe mich
so lange so kann dieses zeitdrucks
gesagt habe sondern dieses nach der
schule nach hause so vier doppelte tore
zu machen somit ersten kunst mutter und
marmelade dann so komme hd gucken beste
leben alter alleine das dass das so ein
charakteristischer geschmack ist dass
der so eine erinnerung somit hoch bringt
so das ist schon echt kraft und die
erdnussbutter verklebt wir so ein
bisschen im gaumen sondern man ist jetzt
aber auch von diesen wenigen sachen so
satt
dann aber nur das ist genau der punkt
das schmeckt gut so wenn du aber blind
dass wir ein gönnt ist das auch nice
dann geht sie aber schlecht und dann
bist du nach 15 minuten wieder hungrig
und dann ist wieder und dann hat dein
land ein übergewichtsproblem das ding
ist heute sind wir zwar kulinarisch in
amerika aber ich würde so gerne
amerikanische serien amerikanische filme
amerikanische musik ohne einschränkung
streamen können es geht ja nicht was das
man ist wir machen das geht mit nord vpn
mit nord vpn habt ihr die möglichkeit
mit einem klick euren standort auf einen
der 5200 server in über 60 ländern zu
wechseln so auch nach amerika das hilft
euch nicht nur dabei eure lieblings
theorien zum beispiel aus amerika von
überall auf der welt zu gucken sondern
ihr könnt streaming anbieter auch zu
einem günstigeren preis abonnieren sie
können zum beispiel auch einfach euren
standort wechseln zu einem ort wo der
streaming anbieter ihrer wahl weniger
geld kostet und den preis von dort
bezahlen und keine angst bank nord lux
müsst ihr euch keine sorgen machen das
internet langsamer wird wenn ihr noch
vor pm bis bleibt quasi genau so schnell
wie es ist und ihr könnt das puffern von
videos oder anderen online inhalten
vermeiden und auch abseits der genannten
punkte ist es natürlich super sinnvoll
nord vpn zu benutzen nicht zuletzt wegen
der bedrohung schutzfunktion die euch
vor malware schutz vor online treckern
und weiteren sachen mit dem internet
nichts zu tun haben sollt klingt auf den
ersten blick in der video beschreibung
www.nordphoto.de ex vp es um ein
exklusives angebot zu erhalten und das
sogar ohne risiko ihr kriegt nämlich 30
tage geld zurück wenn es euch nicht
gefällt also klickt auf den link not vpn
ab vielen dank für die unterstützung wir
machen weiter mit einem tag essen wie in
amerika so nach diesem frühstück freue
ich mich auf ein gesundes amerikanisches
mittagessen und da darf natürlich nichts
geringeres sein als ein film wie steak
sandwich so es ist so dass mac and
cheese unter den sandwich das ist auch
wieder so komplettes comfort food und es
gibt nur ein ort dafür habe letztens in
dem video dort bestellt und da gehen wir
ziehen
[Musik]
ich habe die zubereitung sehen ist auf
die zubereitung gesehen da muss man gar
nicht mehr viel sagen wir hatten ja
letztens auch von raps barbecue hier
diese box mit dem mit dem barbecue
sachen aber ich glaube das ist noch mehr
deren spezialität weil das ist
perfektion ich habe gerade auch auf
keiner gesagt bei der zubereitung ich
habe schon in amerika philippi steak
gegessen und das sei nicht ansatzweise
so gut aus also das kriegst du längst
dich an jeder ecke so ich will glaube
ich aber nicht mit philips tag anfangen
sondern mit dem ruben passt rami
sandwich pass trabi klingt zwar
italienisch ist aber tatsächlich
rumänisch von der von der herkunft der
mageres fleisch sauerkraut grober sind
ein wenig salat und ihr seht schon das
ist simpel aufgebaut und das überzeugt
einzig und allein durch die qualität des
fleisches hast du super lange gebraucht
wird
ich würde ja durch das sauerkraut und so
durch das magere fleisch auch das ist so
übel satisfied aber es schmeckt trotzdem
direkt so nicht ungesund was wirklich
eine seltenheit für die heimische küche
ist dafür die rein amerikanische küche
ist das eine echte sowie honig senf note
der säntis präsent aber es schmeckt
trotz alledem also es ist so sicher wenn
wir gleich ins philips wegweisend das
wird ein anderes geschmackserlebnis aber
du fühlst dich gut so es ist ultra sexy
ist es ein neues geschmacksprofil und es
könnte ganz viel fantasie auch fast sich
so ein bisschen in so eine brauhaus
traditions- küche so in deutschland
einordnen hier haben wir noch tropical
torpedo in den north carolina gebraucht
deshalb
hat mir das ist das tropical torpedo
hast dann willst du eine süßliche note
haben wasser gerste malz hopfen hefe
also ganz normale wir zutaten aber
trotzdem so richtig fruchtig aber jetzt
kommt glaube ich für mich der star der
show willi schießt
sandwich oder das ist wirklich uci ärzte
auch wirklich gut gemeint mit uns also
da ist ganz große portion fleisch
braucht aber guckt jedes mal anders
sieht paprika du hast den alibi salat
den geschmolzenen pro wohl ohne du hast
ja das ist wirklich perversen
[Musik]
ich war noch nicht in philadelphia ich
bin jetzt ein fehler sich das mal was
redest du da noch sagen ich glaube die
bilder sprechen heute wirklich für sie
kann nicht gesagt beide sandwiches habe
ich noch nicht besser gegessen also sind
beides
absoluten 10 von 10 das bsg und heute
abend werden wir mich nur was das essen
sondern auch was geiles machen dafür
müssen wir uns jetzt auf den weg nach
oberhausen machen aber erstmal es sich
das ja auch freunde wissen jetzt
angekommen bei hopp golf ich habe ja
gesagt das wird special wir wurden hier
eingeladen und wir waren schon mal hier
haben wir gegessen getrunken und golf
gespielt und es ist wirklich so
amerikanisch wie etwas nur sein kann
dass sie ist die einzige anlage in
europa sonst gibt es das halt überall in
amerika und auch dubai oder wie auch
immer aber oberhausen ist jetzt nächste
logische schritt auf der weltkarte und
das beste man kann nicht nur golf
spielen sondern ihr kennt mein channel
hier gibt es richtig heißes essen und
das testen wir
[Musik]
ihr lieben ich darf sich einmal
vorstellen bei liegt immer unter dem
auge immer den linken arm durchgestreckt
der zwölfte den bei hannover auf
ich glaube jetzt können wir loslegen
[Musik]
wer kommt
genauso wie meine
schwester ich wollte dass sie top golf
dieses event mit dem video haben weil
wir machen hier kümmern
der ball kommt zu uns wir gehen ans
handy nächsten tag der kranken straße
ist heftigste fahrt kommt zu uns
amerikanischer geht's eigentlich nicht
so man ist wirklich nur am ziel hat
einfach so beste leben ohne irgendwas zu
tun das für mich amerika ok freunde
folgendes geht ja wir haben ein 23 mal
ist die buffalo wings wir haben dort
schicken denn als wir haben die
süßkartoffel profis normale pommes und
überbackenen abschloss meine ich weiß
nicht was ich jetzt noch sagen soll so
das ist endstufe eigentlich also
wirklich wir beginnen das ganze mit
spicy buffalo wings und was ich hier so
krass finde wir haben karotten sticks
und sellerie sticks und rain stressig so
habe ich das in indianapolis gegessen
hat zum ersten mal buffalo wings hatte
ein tippen
[Musik]
wenn wir einen guten haben mit einem
freundin hast hast schon ein zwei bier
getrunken die kommen so an das alter du
merkst du hast also mit richtiger butter
gearbeitet wird so eine buffalo source
ist immer nur links horst mit butter
noch mal ne gute und dann gehst du rein
mit dem caribic
und du fühlst dich wieder frische platte
wir nehmen uns ein official nacho
beginnen die styles sah beginnen die
avocado wir gehen in die creme fraiche
[Musik]
ich sage euch ehrlich das ist für mich
so eine richtige amerikanische
experience du kriegst es hier so einfach
gemacht geile ungesunde scheiße zu essen
und es ist so geil digger schicken
fingers
[Musik]
man am ende des tages ist das einfach
essen das schmecken muss so ne ich liebe
einfach alles ja
ich bin seit einer halben stunde haben
genießen ich kann nicht mehr reden wir
sitzen
sogar ihn ist überlasse es mag ich mache
den schnelldurchlauf für euch unser
bisher steht noch andauert ports mit
entweder strawberry soße oder
schokoladensauce ich liebe alles sehr
daran gerade solche übrigens mit kriegst
du auch wirklich nicht überall a bis z
einfach eine geile erfahrung und wir
machen es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
scheiße ein bisschen spaß essen in
amerika kann man auf jeden fall machen
aber ich glaube ich muss mich enorm
einsetzen wir ein besseres auto
überlegen wir hatten dann auf jeden fall
noch eine gute zeit würde ich mal sagen
und nicht nur das essen war super lecker
sondern es war einfach ein cooler
aufenthalt deshalb danke schön nochmal
ein top kauf dass sie uns so freundlich
aufgenommen habt würde sagen damit geht
auch ein tag essen wie in amerika zu
ende es war einfach nur lecker also es
war wirklich so richtig krank iday
einfach nur und genauso muss ein tag
essen in amerika sein danke fürs zu
sehen bis zum nächsten video und macht